also in the middle of a home renovation
in austin texas
i'm not going to give that woman the
business today i've decided oh really
yeah i didn't like the face the comment
at the end
the comment at the end ruined it we went
into a father
a family a family uh tile place
father and daughter right i thought it
might have been husband and wife
but it was father daughter and we
proceeded to look at all the different
tiles and the things
because i have to i have to get new tile
for my kitchen floor
whether i keep it or rent it or sell it
the tile is bad
we have to get new tile and i went in
and um
i asked for marble immediately why
because it lets them know
that i don't care about them and they
don't matter
to me and if they die or people like
them die
people like me don't get upset do you
see what i mean
when natural disasters affect those
people
i don't care that's why i ask for marble
up front like when i walk in i go hey do
you guys have
marble here and she's like real marble
and i'm like
yeah real marble when a tornado blows
through your mama house
i don't care about that diabetes
infested [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] okay so i said this
so she and i thought
i thought it was a uh a husband and wife
but it was a father-daughter
i think so yeah tile business and we we
were very not and they dissuaded me they
said marble's too expensive and they're
probably right probably right they're
probably right it's too much
it's too much and marble tiles for
[ __ ] fruit loops anyway you want
chunk marble chunks of it
flown in from italy but we can't do that
so
they said porcelain right and that's
good good it's durable
i don't want to put linoleum up well
that's probably how they grew up and
there's nothing wrong with that right
because
linoleum you can piss and [ __ ] on and
just throw orange juice on and it
doesn't bother anyone you can just
get on your knees and wipe it up with a
rag but anyway so i walk in i got out of
uh the car with you and we were just
trying to you know and
so and then i was really hyped about
doing business with these people
truly but then we gave our phone numbers
at the end and
why don't you tell them what happened so
she asked for both of our phone numbers
that's
correct can i give away your area code
for the story i guess i have to right
you yes the area code was in l.a right
she she said they said to ben what's the
area code i said three
i said three two five blank blank blank
blank blank right and they go oh three
two five i go abilene texas they go
nice right and then they go well like
that
they like the area could have abilene
texas by the way the people who cannot
afford to buy the tile
and they go to about you and you give
your number
and they said what's that and i went
beverly hills
and they went she went uh she made a
face and i joked around i said don't
worry
we're voting republican but we're
throwing away this we're throwing around
disgusting amounts of money
i said we're going to throw away this
around just and she kind of made a face
but here's that's why i have to deny the
business because of that
i really have to deny the business
here's the other thing if you work at a
family business
in the tile thing for your father the
reality is
you you like sucking his [ __ ]
there's no other way to really
if you work in a family business with
your dad
you like to suck his [ __ ] or you want to
suck his [ __ ]
you want to [ __ ] him you are unable to
find a man
to then go and build a life with you
want to be near your father
and there's a moment out of every single
day
when you want to get on your knees and
suck the old man off
and just say [ __ ] you god and
jerk his old sweaty dick into your mouth
and
swallow his semen and i find that
unnatural it's not with the laws
of nature so i have to take the business
away from these people
unfortunately you have to call them
early in the morning tell them that we
have some uh there's some family
emergency
i didn't like her face though very over
the top it was
over the top and you know what here's
what you're gonna have to understand
okay you dumb hick
people like me and other people from
california are gonna move in here are
they gonna make your children trans
of course they are dummy but if you had
enough money none of this would happen
you know that capitalism that you people
just jerk off
all day and you take its [ __ ] and you
jam it down your throat
here's what capitalism means dummy it
means that rich people from california
can move into your turd state
and do whatever they want turn your kids
trans
buy your kitchen tile vote for higher
taxes
fund antifa they can do anything and you
can't stop them you know why
because they got the [ __ ] money and
all you [ __ ] give a [ __ ] about
is money right
so shut the [ __ ] up okay
you live in a suburb of austin texas the
worst city in america there's three icu
beds here okay
how i mean literally there's like no icu
beds that's cars are bad
it's so embarrassing it's it's i've been
very clear about my feelings for austin
texas
but again you're rah-rah americanism and
obsession with like
capital i do mother well guess what
capitalism means
[ __ ] it means that i can go
anywhere i want if i have the money and
ruin your life
if i want to ruin your life i can now i
have no interest in ruining your life
i don't vote i really have never voted i
don't like lines
but the point is that the people coming
here are going to ruin your life the
tech people
are going to come here and they're going
to do everything you think they're going
to [ __ ] do
i'm telling you you think this vaccine
is bet they're going to have more
vaccines and i'm
vaccinated i don't even think this one's
there's going to be new ones that are
coming they'll be
vaccines every three months and they'll
just give them to you in your sleep and
you're not going to be able to do
anything about it because you don't have
any money
you see the problem you people are all
obsessed with guns and guns are great
and i understand cut but you don't
really do anything with the guns would
you have a massacre every year
no one's impressed right see the thing
is it's not like you're organizing
assaults on
centers of power you're shooting trees
in your backyard
and the tech people are slowly choking
you
they're slowly taking all the oxygen out
of you and all you're doing is can't
least my money i like my money
so if you like capital it's capital baby
that's it people can come here and do
whatever the [ __ ] they want
and you're gonna have to deal with it
and if you don't [ __ ] like it well
too [ __ ] bad
you have to make enough money to stop
them
how about that you've gotta make more
money than the tech people and good luck
good luck slinging linoleum tile if
you're gonna have more money
than them so i don't think i can give
her the business it saddens me
because i actually think they'd do a
good job they did yeah they were good
but i just i don't i just you know what
it is it's that over-the-top
cuntiness that to me i
feel like you know what
when i saw her do that i i had a feeling
you were gonna back out of the whole
thing
it was a real it was over the top well
you know what it is
she doesn't understand that she doesn't
have any power we didn't fight through
lines of people to get in there
okay we were the only people in there
but she doesn't and the father
the father even looked you're like kind
of like why are you doing that why don't
you just come suck my [ __ ]
because they wanna [ __ ] each other it's
incest it's truly incest
and and that's okay because they have
all these weird codes they're like i
don't like democrats but
i like sucking my daddy off
like even when she was like playful like
he came over she's like daddy don't step
on my clothes because he stepped on her
you know people in austin like women in
austin are um uh disgusting
and they were like she was wearing like
balloon green balloon pants and
everything
because they don't know how to dress
here the women the women here are like
uh
you know they're cows you know they're
like disgusting drug addicts
so uh she's wearing like a green balloon
pants and he stepped on and she's like
daddy don't step on my pants
but i thought she wanted at that point i
think like he wanted to just kind of
just hit her in the ass like if we
weren't there i think he would have just
taken his big hand
and just hit her in the ass and then
snuck a finger up
snuck a finger up the back and then they
would have went back and like
[ __ ] on like tile like you know like i
like to [ __ ] my
daughter on cold tile i like to [ __ ] i
like to feel it on cold
[ __ ] tile because they're doing
incest is my why my
why i say that